bonjour
alors on
moi je
or
c'est comme ça
c'est ma deuxième participation donc
c'est pas si peu le département
les ja de voir des entreprises bénédicte
et noble âge vous présente pas la
plantation en ville ça tu représentes
rigoler confiturier la réunion donc
beaucoup plus large
alors plutôt dans le nord et l'est
safari la montagne ça me dois aussi là
personnellement je
on a envie le public a tout pour les
il y aura le public vous attendez on
baptise
[Musique]
c'est vrai que finalement que l'habitude
élections sur
faire un tri
car je viens parce que on dit à 3 ans et
maintenant nous sommes vraiment le salon
c'est quelque chose qui a la qualité des
projets de développement comme du
parquet de présentation la mouture je
pense que sa rencontre
voilà fait
jean la colle
on subit ben voilà il ya quatre ans
après tables de plo faut qu'on a un
produit que faire mieux présenter
le standard en fait
jusqu'à quand on se donne
que l'excellence présent on
médaille mais derrière on espère
quand tu as deux ans gouvernement vous
avez vous encore à
[Musique]
ban à la presse par action
d
west ham
voilà bonhomie
or qui est beaucoup moins connu
la scuderia
connaître c'est intéressant
c'est une cavale
le mythique maracana terroir du sam
hanna le meilleur liquid e
le canadien peut dire
médaille d'or médaille d'or voilà sur
ces dollars et puis la médaille
turner qui vient aussi de sable
de grandes étoffes ce coup là
les comme ça qu'on fait pour vous
cette épreuve de karting
puis c'est au tour de vis a produit
en fait les fleurs et son entière
on souffre et basse mais ce président
[Applaudissements]
que ça donne un peu
apparemment c'est que ce propos la santé
monté seul département les podiums
va t'en aller à la production locale la
production locale leur plan local c'est
celle qu'on va sano cru